mind your decisions presto Walker here
this problem is adapted from the Tesla
test in Argentina and I think Pedro for
suggesting it every day at 7 a.m.
Pedro walks from home to school on
Monday
he walks at a rate of 95 meters per
minute and he reaches school one minute
late on Tuesday
Pedro makes the same walk at a hundred
and five meters per minute and he
reaches school one minute early
then on Wednesday Pedro walks at some
rate and he reaches school exactly on
time there are two parts to this
question first
what time did Pedro reach the school on
Wednesday and second what speed did he
walk on Wednesday pause the video if
you'd like to give this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
we'll get started with the formula that
distance is equal to rate times time
this is usually abbreviated D is equal
to R times T on Monday pedra walks at a
rate of 95 meters per minute and reaches
one minute late so the distance is equal
to the rate of 95 multiplied by the time
of T plus one we have a similar equation
for Tuesday here the rate is equal to
105 and the time is equal to t minus 1
because he's one minute early now we
focus on the system of two equations
we'll distribute the rates and then
we'll solve by subtracting the second
equation from the first this eliminates
the variable D we get 0 is equal to 10 t
minus 200 we then solve for T we add 200
to both sides and then divide by 10 so T
is equal to 20 and we're dealing with
minutes so T is equal to 20 minutes
since Pedro starts every day at 7 a.m.
that means on Wednesday he reaches at
7:20 a.m. that's part one now on
Wednesday he goes at some speed and
reaches on time what was his speed well
go back to the equation for Monday and
substitute in for the time we then solve
for the distance D as 95 times 21 and
that will be equal to 1995 we can then
use our equation D is equal to RT on
Wednesday and we need to solve for R so
1995 is equal to R times 20 we then
solve for R which will be 1995 over 20
and we get the answer of 99.75 and that
will be meters per minute so here are
the two answers pedra reaches at 7:20
a.m. and he goes at a speed of 99.75
meters per minute it's a pretty fun
problem thanks for making mind your
decisions one of the best channels on
YouTube thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]